[Music]
the word theory can be used to mean
something speculative and tentative in
everyday speech it probably usually is
used in that sense scientists very often
use it in a much more positive sense I
think the easiest ways to use the
ordinary language word fact in the
ordinary language sense of the word fact
evolution is a fact
that makes it a fact is partly fossil
evidence partly compare comparative
evidence looking at modern species and
comparing their bones their organs their
structures generally and especially
their molecules their genes at a
molecular level this is extremely
persuasive and powerful evidence you
compare the the genes of animals and
plants you find that they the pattern of
resemblance is a tree a branching tree
and that branching tree could only be a
family tree other very persuasive
evidence is there the geographical
distribution of animals and plants on
islands and continents they are exactly
where we should expect them to be if
evolution were a fact